LEE BOONSTRA: Hi, everybody.
My name is Lee Boonstra.
I work as a customer
engineer for Google
from the Amsterdam office.
And you will see me mostly
visiting banks and insurances,
as we, at Google, defined
our teams in pods.
And they asked
me, Lee, would you
like to go to Paris to give this
presentation about extending
G Suite functionalities
with business applications?
And I said, yeah, I'm sure.
I'm a developer.
I love to share my knowledge
about building cool apps.
So yes, I would
like to go to Paris.
Are there any developers
here, in the room?
A few.
How many people have ever
seen code or read code?
Some more, right?
So this will be a
technical session,
but I'm going to share with
you all the secrets on how
you can build applications
with the use of G Suite.
And typically,
there are two ways
in how you can build
applications with G Suite.
You can take that
Apps Script approach--
that means I'm staying
within the G Suite domain
and I put my own
code on top of that.
So it is within G Suite.
Let's say, in Docs or Sheets.
And I put my own code
within the doc or sheet.
And that way, I make
it more advanced
or more conformed to my needs.
Back in the past, people used
to use, for example, in Office,
they used Macros and
Visual Basic that way.
We, in G Suite,
have Apps Script.
So that is one approach.
The other approach
is I already have
my own existing application,
or my own app, or website,
and I like to take G
Suite functionalities
within my own app.
So the benefit is then
I'm not, internally,
within the G Suite domain.
Now I can be on any domain.
And I just move the data from
G Suite or the functionalities
from G Suite within the app.
Now there's actually another
way in how you can create
applications with G Suite.
And maybe you have seen this,
earlier today, in the keynote.
That is through App Maker.
And I will show
you that as well.
App Maker is our visual
design, drag-and-drop editor,
where you very quickly
can create apps.
You don't need to be a developer
to create applications.
For the people
that earlier said,
I've never seen code before--
yeah, you guys can
create apps as well.
After this all, I will hand
over to Laura from LumApps.
And she will explain what
they did with their company--
what kind of applications
they created.
So very exciting.
All right.
Let's start with the first
approach-- the Apps Script
approach.
Apps Script is a serverless
JavaScript runtime for G Suite.
Serverless-- that
means not that there
are no servers, because there
are servers, but they are
are somewhere in a
Google data center
and we just don't
care about that.
But we write JavaScript code.
And it's been executed
somewhere in a data center.
And you can do this to
create the G Suite add ons.
Now these add ons
for G Suite, they
make use of the OAuth
2 model, so they
are secure within
the G Suite domain.
There is a script editor within
G Suite that you can use,
where you can start
coding your code.
And you can make
use of triggers.
So for example, when
you open a document,
it starts executing code.
Now these add ons--
you can bring them
to a Marketplace
and then you can download them.
You can also download them
from the document itself.
Then you go to Add
Ons, Get Add Ons,
and download these add ons
to make it more advanced.
Now let's look into
the entry points--
how can I get
started with G Suite?
The first entry point is
like container bound apps.
Now what is a
container bound app?
That means I have one
particular Google Doc or one
particular sheet, and every
time, when I open that sheet,
I execute my own code,
my own Apps Script code.
That is a container
bound application.
So it's for one
particular document.
And you can get access to
that particular document
by running
DocumentApp.getActiveDocument,
SpreadsheetApp.g
etActiveSpreadheet,
or FormApp.getActiveForm.
And it has these triggers,
so every time you
open the document,
you can execute code,
or every time you edit the
document, it executes code.
And the other approach that is
not for a particular document,
that can be any document
or any spreadsheet--
you go to scripts.google.com.
And you get the editor.
But your code that you
will execute in this case
can be for any document.
So usually, what
people do is they
create a picker or
a dropdown where
you can select the
document where you want
to run your code on top of.
Or you create a new
document or a new sheet,
and you run code on
that type of sheet.
This typically done for add ons.
Like when you download an
add on from the Marketplace,
they probably chose this way.
So not a container bound script,
it's just a regular Apps Script
application.
There is another way in
how you can create code
in Apps Script that
is for AdWords.
We're not going to cover that.
And the last way is
through App Maker.
Although it is a visual
design, drag-and-drop editor,
it is still possible
to add some code,
in case you want to create a
really advanced application.
We'll see this later.
Now how can you write
Apps Script code?
Let's take a look
into an example
of how I can create or
modify just standard G Suite
functionality with my own code.
Usually what I do is I go
and look into the docs.
In the docs, they
give great guides
and they explain the whole
APIs that you can start using.
So I always have that open in
another tab, in the browser.
And then I finally
start writing code.
So in this case, what
I'm kind of built
is a conference app, where I
have a shared slides folder.
And my coworkers, they can
upload a slide in my folder.
And every time people
upload slides in the folder,
I get an email.
It's a very simple example,
but I think it's a use case--
getting an email based on when a
file has being edited, I think,
is a very common use case.
So we start doing that.
We go into Drive, where we
create a new Apps Script file.
That is the file that
we will start to use.
The next thing is we need this
slides folder, where people
will upload the files in.
And to do that, we need to
make sure that it's shared.
So within your drive,
you can say, OK,
this is a shared folder.
You right click it.
You set link sharing on.
And you usually get a pop up.
And it also tells you the ID of
the folder that will be shared.
And that is the ID that we
need to reference in our code,
so that our code knows,
OK, this is the folder
that we need to
start monitoring.
So there you go.
I start writing a variable
with the ID of the folder.
Now the next thing is I start
writing some logics here.
And the first thing that
I'm doing here is I say,
OK, I'll take that folder and
I'll get a real folder object.
And from that folder
object, I want
to loop through all the files
that are in this folder.
And I save that to a variable.
This will be an array.
So later, I can look
through that array
and start doing things.
I create another
variable called Props.
And Props, in this case,
is like a very little store
where you can store data.
And it's like a
persistent layer.
So it's very simple, but it's
a way you can save files.
Even after you
close the document,
you still can store
some information there.
And we need to store
information because I
need to mark if I have seen this
slide before or not, because I
don't want to have, by the
end of the month, hundreds
e-mails because it started
e-mailing out the same files
every time.
All right.
I create a variable,
New Files Array.
So here, I will flag it--
like, OK, this file is new.
And then I start looping
through all the files
that are in the
shared slides folder.
And here comes the trick--
I say, OK, if I have
nothing in my Props store--
so if I have nothing
stored or saved yet--
then I'm going to create
a key in this store that
references the file that
I am viewing right now.
And the reason why I'll
do that is so next time,
I will skip this.
But if you don't
skip it, then it
adds it to the New Files Array.
And when it comes to
the New Files Array,
then it's the last
thing that it does.
It's like, OK,
there are new files,
new slides have been uploaded,
I need to email these slides.
And that's what
the Gmail app does.
This is Google Gmail API.
There's a standard integrated
within Google Apps Script.
You can start making
use of these API calls.
You don't need to
download anything or start
authenticating anything because
it's all standard there.
So within 20 lines, I
created this functionality.
I can start playing
the functionality.
I run the Play button.
I say execute the
process function.
And I'm good to go, right?
I make sure that I
have logging enabled,
so every time when
something will be emailed,
I will also get a log message.
I can do simple logging--
that is just with logger.log.
But I can also do
more advanced logging.
And that goes through the
Google Cloud Stackdriver.
So if you really want to
have row numbers and so,
then the Stackdriver
is much, much nicer.
There, you see this
is the email and how
it will look like in my Gmail
when I get the slides being
e-mailed to me.
Now there is one
thing that I did--
I executed the
process function once,
just for testing purposes.
But what I need to
do is I need to have
this run in the background,
so that every time when
somebody uploads
slides, I get the email.
So to do that,
you need triggers.
I'm going to set up
a project trigger.
And you see, this is my
first code that I created,
so there is no
trigger created yet.
So I click on that link.
And then it says, yeah, you
need to authenticate first.
We need authorization.
This is secure.
We don't want everybody to
get access to these Gmail APIs
without giving the right
permissions for it.
It's OAuth 2, so we need
to review the permissions.
Usually, this is
all out of the box.
It happens for you.
So you get this pop up.
And then I say,
OK, I am Lee and I
like to retrieve e-mails
through my Gmail,
so I authorize
Gmail, in this case.
And I also give you access
to my slides folder,
which is in Drive.
So I allow that.
Now I can finally
set up the triggers.
And what I'm doing
here is I create
a time driven trigger that
runs in the background,
every five minutes.
And then I get the email.
In case you think, oh,
this Apps Script, I'd
like to try it out
with that, go ahead.
There are actually some
extras coming soon.
We will have support
for Gmail add ons.
So if you want to
extend on top of Gmail,
that is possible to Apps Script.
We will have support
for Slides, so that you
can extend on top of Slides.
If you're a heavy
Slides user, that
might be nice that you can
put your own functionalities
on top of that.
If you try that out, there is an
early access program for this.
So you can go to this URL,
and then you can sign up,
and you can start
playing around with that.
And also, what's coming soon--
those are mobile add ons.
So the add ons also
run on a mobile phone.
That's pretty cool.
Now let's take a look into
the second approach, where
I said that this is
the approach where
you have your own application
and you want to integrate
Google data, or G Suite data,
or G Suite functionalities
within your own app--
so your own app, on your
own website, for example.
You can do that through
the Google APIs.
Google has lots of
clients' SDKs for you.
So whether you're a Java
developer, or a PHP developer,
or Go, or Python, or, like
me, JavaScript and Node.js.
You can download all these
SDKs from the website.
They're all there.
And such an SDK, they contain
all the Google endpoints.
So for all Google products,
there are SDKs available.
So if you think, I
like Google Maps,
you can extend your own
applications with Google Maps,
or you can extend your own
applications with Gmail,
or Google Docs functionalities.
This is all integrated
within these client SDKs.
So let's look into an example
of how you would do this.
Like I said already, I
am a Node.js developer,
so I would prefer nodes.
So what I do is I go to the
node package manager page
and I start downloading
the Google API.
And then the next thing
that you need to do
is you need to go to the
Google Cloud control panel.
And then you look for
that particular API
that you want to make use of.
So in my case, I'm going to
create a Gmail application,
so I need to enable the Gmail
API within my Cloud console.
This way, I can
monitor and I can also
see how many times people
have been using my Gmail APIs.
So you enable that
in the console.
The next thing is you need
to set up credentials.
This is a very similar
process as if you would
create applications in GCP.
So you create a
service account, you
can download an adjacent
key on your machine.
And for the Gmail API and for,
probably, all the other APIs,
then you start writing code.
So where in Apps
Script it went out
of the box-- the OAuth
functionality-- here,
we need to trigger
that with code.
And the way how OAuth 2
works, in general, is you
have this key.
And with that key, you will
log into your Google account.
So you get just a Google pop up.
You get a Google pop up when
you go to a particular URL.
So, usually, in
your application,
you create a button that says
Set Up This Functionality.
You might remember
that from applications
on your mobile phone
that make use of Google.
And, usually, it
opens a Google page
in the background
with a Google log in.
You need to log into
your Google account.
And what happens in
the background is--
this is after you've logged
into that Google account--
they will redirect
you to another page.
But they have this
token being generated.
And that token will be
written down on your device
or it will be written
down on your machine.
And that is a bearer token that,
later on, will give you access
to your Gmail API or
to your Google APIs.
And you usually set it
up with an expiry date.
So for a certain frame, you
can get access to that API
without going through this
process and by logging
into Google every time.
Here, you can see
an example code.
Now this is already a
little bit more trickier,
but, honestly, it
wasn't that difficult
because I just copied it
from the Google Docs site.
They have this example
of an OAuth flow,
and I could just copy,
paste it, and it works.
Basically, it says I used
the Node.js Google API.
I need to define the scope.
So in this case, I'm
making use of Gmail.
So I manually need to say
this is the Gmail scope.
Where in Apps Script,
it automatically
showed up in a pop
up. here, I need
to type it and tell
Google, this is the scope
that I want to use.
I also need to specify the
path where, on my machine,
the token will be stored.
And then I just copy
it over the methods
that will take care
of the authorization.
And it will work out of the box.
And then you can start
using Gmail code.
And Gmail code-- that could
look like this-- for example,
you say,
gmail.users.messages.list.
I specify my authentication.
That is the object that
was saved on my machine.
I tell who is the user ID that
I want to read to Gmail logics
from.
Well, in this case, that's me.
And what are my querying?
I'm querying, I want to
read all the unread email.
So I want to get that.
And I get that here.
If it went wrong,
it will log it.
But if it's OK, I will save
it to the e-mails variable.
And in this case, it
contains email IDs.
And I could look through
the arrays with IDs,
and get the full email bodies,
and you can display an email.
I used this code, actually,
for playing around
with my Google Home.
Google Home can
read up my e-mails.
So I did it this way.
Now if you want to make
use of this kind of stuff,
there are API for G Suite--
for every G Suite product.
So I mentioned Gmail, but there
are APIs for Contacts, APIs
for Sheets, for Sites, for
you name it-- everything.
We have seen App Maker and
we have seen Google APIs.
Now let's take a look
into our App Maker.
App Maker-- this is our
visual design editor.
So you don't need
to be a developer
to create Google applications.
You can very quickly
drag and drop it.
It's a SaaS application.
That means that you go to
App Maker in your browser,
and it opens it in
the browser, and you
can start making use of it.
It has a bunch of benefits.
I mean, obviously,
it's a very fast way
to create great
applications this way
because you drag and drop
components on the stage.
But it also has
data binding, which
means that if I create
data in my application--
and then you find a model.
Let's say a model
would be a car.
Let's say I'm going to collect
car information in my app.
And if you would
define a car model,
you would write
out the properties
of a car, which is number of
wheels, the color, the brand.
So you define the structure
of your objects in a model.
And because of
automatically data binding,
it recognizes that data.
So if you drag View
Components on the stage,
like a table, or a
grid, or a chart,
it will automatically recognize
the models that belong to it
and automatically show it.
You don't need to code
anything for that.
It's nicely integrated
within the G Suite domain.
You can make use of a Cloud SQL.
So the GCP Cloud SQL-- you
can implement it in your apps.
But if you don't
have GCP Cloud SQL
and you just want to make
use of G Suite on its own,
you can also just store
the data in Google Drive.
And it's secure because it's
within the Google domain,
so all the security rules
are applied and have
been whitelistd to
do G Suite, itself.
So this is not a solution
for creating apps
for the Google Play Store
or the iOS App Store.
No.
This is more a solution
for internal applications,
like an internal HR
application, or an internal CRM,
or tracking applications.
There are lots of
reasons why businesses
need internal apps that run
within their own firewall.
And this time, they
don't need to hire
developers to build this stuff.
No.
They can do it themselves.
They can prototype it
quickly or they could even
build full life applications.
So you don't need to be a
developer to make use of it.
It is point and click,
so you can drag and drop
all the components.
It's supported by
open standards,
so it makes use of HTML5.
So JavaScript use HTML.
And it also has the nice
material design look and feel,
so your applications really
look like Android apps.
Really nice.
Now you have me here,
talking about this.
Now let me give you a demo, so
I can show you how this works.
So can we switch to
my machine, please?
Cool.
So what you see here--
this is the SaaS
application of App Maker.
And I recorded it
myself, so I'll
make sure that I can do
it within the time frame.
The first thing
that I am doing here
is I am changing the
application name.
Now what kind of
application are we creating?
We're creating a
to-do application.
I think that's the
most common application
for when you're new.
So I create this application.
Now I'm going to select a
data model or a data object.
And, like I said, you
can save data in Drive
or you can save data in
an in Google Cloud SQL.
I'm going to create a save
data in the Google Drive.
So I select a model
in the Google Drive.
Let's do that.
There are other ways as well,
but we're using just Drive.
So I select Drive
and click Next.
Now I give a model name.
So in this case, the
model will be Tasks.
A task because it's
a to-do application.
I can start creating
fields for a task.
Now what kind of
fields do I need?
I need to have a task name.
So I create a string
field for task.
I need another field.
In this case, I need
a field for date
because I need to say by when
this task needs to be done.
So, in this case,
it's a date field.
I create another field--
this is a Boolean field-- to
mark if the task is completed--
yes or no.
So I called the task
Fields Completed.
It's a Boolean.
All right.
I switch back to the page.
This is the stage.
I rename it.
This will be the main
page, so I set it to Main.
I can start dragging
widgets on the stage.
So in this case, I'm
dragging a grid component.
It's like a little table.
Did you see?
It also recognized my task
model, out of the box.
This is true data binding.
So it already knows, OK, this
table will save task data.
I drag it on the stage.
And you can change the
column headers, if you want.
I don't do that right now.
I'm going to select another
component on the stage.
And in this case, it's a form.
And this will be
the View/Edit form.
So every time I select
a task in my grid,
then I want to
showcase, in this form,
the information about this task.
And you see what I'm doing now--
I'm resizing everything, so
that it's nicely in great sizes.
I can drag another
button on the stage.
This button is for when
I create new tasks.
And when I want to create a
new task, what I want to do
is I want to show a pop up,
where I can start typing.
So I give the
button the name Add.
Automatically, if
you switch the style
from the button and the
button is called Add,
then it comes with
this nice plus icon.
So that already looks nice
and material design-ish.
And now I can start
creating another page.
This will be up pop up
for creating a new task.
Yes.
I'll start dragging another
component on the screen.
And in this case, it's a form.
This is the Add form for
creating new task data.
Again, through data binding,
it recognizes the model.
I'm just changing
the layout here.
So I want to make it
like a little small.
I want to make the
pop up also small,
so that it's nicely in
the center of my page.
I can change the spacing here.
And I set the width.
Right.
Now I need another button.
In this case, I want
to close the dialog.
And I am not filling
in any task date,
I should be, also, able
to remove the pop up.
So I'm dragging another
button on the stage.
I give it the name, Close.
Then it recognized
the cross icon.
And what I'm doing here
is I'm binding an action.
So when I did this,
I said, I want
to bind the Close
action on the pop up,
so that it automatically
knows that it
needs to close the pop up.
There's no code here,
it's just selecting it
because App Maker understands
that that's just a common thing
to do for a pop up.
I go back to the Main screen.
I need to open the
pop up as well,
so I need to add also
some functionality here.
I can say Open Dialog.
And then, which dialog?
Well that's the Add screen.
I see that I gave
it the wrong name.
I called it Added.
It should be Add.
So I'm changing
that back to Add.
And then I need to
make sure that, also,
when you have the action,
that the action points
to the right object.
So in this case, I need
to say the on click
will be on Add page.
Yes.
So I'm setting it there--
open dialog for the Add page.
Cool.
So I'm done now.
I can hit the Preview button.
And what it does, it opens
now my browser screen.
If it's the first
time when you do this,
then, again, you will
see a Google pop up,
where you need to give
the right permissions.
I did it already.
But here, you can see the
application running live.
And you see, these are
like the nice components.
I can start editing data in it.
It created new tasks.
And when I select
a task, you see
that it's been highlighted
in the view screen.
And I can hit Completed and
it marks it also in the grid
that it was completed.
So that is true data binding.
This took me about five minutes.
And again, you've seen that
there's not much coding here.
Let me switch back to my slides.
So what I just did, there
was no coding involved.
But I can imagine that
there are use cases
that you do want to
write Apps Script code
or you do want to
write JavaScript code.
Maybe because you want to
make use of other Google APIs,
like Gmail, for example.
And you want to integrate
that in your apps.
That is possible.
There is a script
editor in Apps Maker
and you can start
writing your code.
This can be Apps Script code.
So again, the serverless
JavaScripts that run somewhere
in the Google data center.
Or it can be normal
JavaScript code
and then it runs in the browser.
In case you think like, oh,
I would like to try this out,
this App Maker, you can sign
up for early access program,
so you can start
playing around with this
and create your
own applications.
Just go to this URL.
And I think somebody
will approve it.
And then you can start using App
Maker within your own G Suite
domain.
And with this, I would like to
hand it over to Laura LumApps
because they created lots of
nice business applications
as well.
Give me a big hand.
LAURA WIEST PILLOIS: Thank you.
Thank you, Lee.
So I'm Laura.
I'm marketing operations
manager at LumApps.
And I'm very excited to be here.
First of all, what is LumApps?
LumApps, in a nutshell,
is a social internet
recommended by Google.
It's a combination of an
internet and a social network.
We fully integrate with
G Suite and you can use
LumApps on any mobile device.
And we have two core features
that are pretty cool.
We have a user directory and
we have personalized content,
meaning that the user
gets the right content,
at the right time, and it gets
delivered to the right person.
So more than words--
I'm going to show
you a quick video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Imagine you could connect all
employees in a smart internet.
That is LumApps.
LumApps is a completely
re-imagined enterprise portal
that delivers the right
content to the right people
at the right time.
LumApps brings all your
communication together
in one place.
Corporate news, profiled
information, key figures,
and social media feeds--
it's all there.
It's about having access to
your Google Apps in one click.
A quick glance at your
emails or calendar
will let you know what's
important in your working day.
We know how valuable your
business applications are,
so all the tools you already
use integrate directly
into a dashboard.
A global search puts what you're
looking for in your hands,
instantly.
Connecting with the right
people has never been easier.
Reach out and start
working together.
LumApps notifies you when
an item needs your attention
and shows important
topics directly
in your activity stream.
Follow people and join projects
to stay informed in real time.
And share ideas
whenever you want.
With the power of
Google Analytics,
you can measure the adoption
to make sure all employees love
their portal.
Spread your corporate culture
by designing a place that
fits your brand identity.
Join hundreds of companies
who have already transformed
the way they work with LumApps.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
LAURA WIEST PILLOIS:
So why LumApps?
What makes LumApps so special?
First of all, let's go back to
our users and our customers.
What are they telling us?
If you work for a big
organization, you work in IT,
you're a communications
specialist,
what are the pain
points that you're
going to face when
using an internet
and when dealing with internet?
First of all, the
interaction capabilities
are very, very limited
with my internet platform.
If you think of, what is
the purpose of an internet?
It's a database-- so you want
to find the right documents,
the right people--
but you also want to
start a conversation
with your employees
and start developing
a sense of community.
So if there's no interaction
capability, you have a problem.
Next pain point is, I can't use
my internet on mobile devices.
This is specifically
true for organizations
that work in retail, or
distribution, or people
who work remotely.
If they can't access
and use your internet
from mobile devices,
you have a problem.
The next problem is pretty
generic and common--
it's employees rarely
use my internet.
It turns out maybe I can't use
my internet on mobile devices
or it's currently
not being used.
The next problem is, my internet
is just a page of links.
So it's very good if you're
looking for the right document,
but how can I engage my
employees and exchange
with them?
Next pain point is pretty
critical-- the look and feel
of my internet is
old and outdated.
It's specifically
true for companies
who are very innovative.
So from the outside,
you want to reflect
an image of being an
innovative company,
but if, from the inside,
you're not innovative,
then you have a problem.
You want to have a
platform that's modern
and that has a
modern look and feel.
The search function is broken.
Could be a problem if
I'm looking for a person
or if I'm looking
for a document that's
really critical for my
project or for my business.
The last pain point is also
really, really important.
You're going to
have businesses who
are going to want to have
all their applications in one
place.
So if my internet does not
integrate all the business
apps and all the apps that are
very, very critical for all
my entities, turns
out my internet is not
going to be used as well.
So we've covered the
problems and now we
come to the solution.
The solution is LumApps.
You have three key points--
LumApps is the unique
digital workplace
where a user gets
delivered the right content
to the right person
at the right time.
We integrate with
G Suite very deeply
and you also have the social
collaborative functions
integrated in the platform.
Besides those three
points, LumApps
is responsive,
meaning that you have
the same quality of
information on any device
that you're connecting to.
It's multilingual in the
sense that the content
is displayed with the language
of the connected user.
You can customize
LumApps to your liking
with a personalized
graphical identity,
depending on your
brand identity as well.
And if you're an
internet project leader,
you might want to analyze the
way people use your platform
and react.
So that's when the analytic
feature of LumApps comes in.
I'm going to go
over four simple use
cases to show you
what our customers are
doing with LumApps.
The first customer is Veolia.
So Veolia is our first,
historical customer.
It's a French,
international company.
They have activities around
energy and utilities.
And they have external growth.
They grow externally a lot.
So they need to develop
a sense of belonging
and a sense of community
to all their employees.
So we created the
first internet portal
for them named One Veolia.
One Veolia means one
unique entry point
to have a one-to-one
conversation with every Veolia
employee.
One also means a single place
to get corporate information
and local information.
They've also developed a top 500
portal dedicated to the top 500
managers, where they
publish premium information.
So they allow sensitive,
relevant, and critical content
to be delivered to
the top 500 managers.
And they also want to increase
the engagement of those top 500
managers.
One of our other
customers is also
in another industrial giant.
It's Valeo.
Valeo is the leader in
auto parts manufacturing.
And they're also early
adopters of innovative Cloud
technologies.
So they go Google in 2007 and
they also went to all digital.
They created 18,000
Google sites.
So they were looking for a
Best-in-Class application
in terms of internet projects.
And so they chose LumApps
for its modern look and feel.
They also really liked the
profiling functionality,
which I've told you
earlier about providing
the right content to the right
person at the right time.
They've created a top 300
management corporate portal.
And they also use the social
capabilities of LumApps,
in the sense that
they've created
a collaborative platform
for all the R&D teams.
No matter where you
are in the world,
you have all the information
within this community.
We change worlds.
We go to Cooperl.
Cooperl is the French
agricultural co-operative.
Co-operative means that
people are scattered
around the territory, so you
need to create engagement
with a sense of community.
And they want to drive
traffic to their internet.
And they've used two drivers
which are pretty cool.
They have used our
Users Directory.
Which means, for example, from
the Users Directory function,
you can launch a Hangout
or send an email directly
from someone's profile.
All the changes that
you make are also
directly synced with Google.
They've also used
a second driver
to drive traffic
to their internet--
internal ads.
So they've developed an internal
Leboncoin-- or internal eBay--
to let other employees know
that they're selling their car
or they're selling
their real estate.
And they've also developed
internal ads for carpooling,
if they want to share
rides with other employees.
And the last use case I
want to present is Etam.
So you probably all
know this brand.
It's a fashion or a
French clothing retailer.
They have more than 4,000
stores in 52 countries.
So the information is
spread in field operation.
And there's no real connection
to corporate headquarters.
They go Google and
they need to extend
the use of Google applications.
They want to go further
in collaboration,
so they choose LumApps.
And they choose LumApps
because we integrate fully
with all Google applications.
They also choose LumApps
because, in every store,
you have two to three
tablets that the employees
in the stores use.
So they were particularly
sensitive to the fact
that we integrate also
any mobile device.
They've chosen a name
for their internet,
which is called L'INTRA.
And L'INTRA is dedicated
to four stores.
And it has four
different spaces.
For example, there's
a space for brand,
there's a space, also, for the
corporate headquarters speaking
to the field operations.
So I thought I
would just show you,
with a visual summary,
what LumApps does.
So you have all the devices
that we connect at the center.
We integrate the business apps.
You get corporate and local
news delivered directly
to your computer, your
tablet, or your smartphone.
You have this user directory
with an organizational chart
also embedded, the social
and the communities
that you can create, and it
also integrates integration
with Google Drive.
Now you know what we sell,
you know our product.
I thought I would share
something about who we are
and what's our story.
So this is us.
We're about 70 people
and constantly growing.
We have offices in
Paris, London, New
York, San Francisco,
and we recently
opened Austin and Tokyo.
We have a worldwide
partners network.
And this year, we raised funds.
We raised $8 million.
And this is an article
that was published
last week in Les Echos.
You can find it online.
And it explains our
philosophy, our strategy,
and you can also get
to know our founders.
We started our business in
2015 by addressing G Suite
customers.
In 2016, we were lucky enough
to be officially recommended
for G Suite by Google.
What does it mean to be
officially recommended
by Google?
It means that Google and
LumApps product teams
are working together to
align their product roadmaps.
It also means that LumApps
is built on the Google Cloud
platform and we meet Google's
standards in terms of security.
And it means that LumApps
provides a full integration
with G Suite.
And this full integration is
certified by Google itself.
And in 2017, during the Google
Cloud Summit in San Francisco,
we received the Solution
Innovation of the Year Award.
So from this side, you
can see that we have
a whole bunch of customers.
What's important
to note is that we
address all sizes,
all industries,
and we can also
address companies
that are present globally.
We have over 35% market
share now, in France.
And today, around 1.4 million
people use LumApps daily.
So that's it for me.
If you want to know more,
you can write me an email
or you can go to our booth.
We're Booth 5.
It's right across the hall.
And also, one last,
cool feature is
that you can download
LumApps from the Google
Marketplace for a free trial.
So you can test,
try, and have fun
with the product for 30 days.
So you should go
and check it out.
Thank you for your time.
Thanks.